تغرق تونس في ازمتها متعدده الاوجه
والابعاد فيكثف الاتحاد العام التونسي
للشغل مساعيه لاحداث ثغره في جدار المازق
السياسي يتعلق الامر بمبادره قال الاتحاد
انها تهدف لانقاذ البلاد من الانهيار
والفوضى بعيدا عن التجاذبات السياسيه جديد
تلك المساعي هو ان المبادره ستضم عباده
المحامين والرابطه التونسيه للدفاع عن
حقوق الانسان وقد تتوسعوا لتضم منظمات
اخرى
الامين العام للمنظمه النقابيه نور الدين
الطبوبي اوضح ان مبادره الاتحاد لن تكون
على حساب اي طرف لكنه حرص على تاكيد ان
الاتحاد لن يسمح للسلطه والمعارضه
بالتلاعب بالبلاد التي قال انها تعاني
اربعه مشاكل اساسيه قانونيه ودستوريه
واقتصاديه واجتماعيه كما اعتبر اسطنبول ان
الديمقراطيه ليست سكا على بياض وان
التونسيين فقدوا الثقه في الجميع
ورغم اسلوبها الهادئ تبدو تلك التصريحات
مواجهه ضمنا الى الرئيس قيس سعيد وما
سماها الطبوبي سياسه المراوغه التي ينتجها
كما تبدو تصريحات المسؤول النقابي مرتبطه
بسياق الانتخابات التشريعيه الاخيره التي
سجلت ادنى نسبه اقتراع في البلاد منذ ثوره
الرئيس التونسي يمضي قدما في تحميل
مسؤوليه الازمه للغارقين في الفساد متعهدا
بملاحقتهم دون ان يسميهم او يحددهم كعادته
اما العزوف الانتخابي الواسع فلا يعني لدى
سعيد فشل الاستحقاق الانتخابي والنسبه علي
اضاءتها هي افضل من نسبه
99% التي كانت تحدث سابقا على حد قوله
وبينما ترفع المعارضه السياسيه نداءاتها
للرئيس بالتنحي تتزايد المخاوف في تونس من
ان تلجا السلطه الى التصعيد ضد خصومها
استباقا الاحتمال ان ينفذ اتحاد الشغل
تهديداته احتلال الشوارع والدخول في
اضرابات انقطاعيه واسعه تاكد منها حتى
الان اضراب قطاع النقل برا وبحرا وجوا
يومي الخامس والعشرين والسادس والعشرين من
يناير المقبل وهي تواريخه مشحونه في
الذاكره التونسيه
بالدلالات والمعاني